let's ask the tough questions today how
many bodies does it take for a woman to
become a hoe
yeah
I want to start with the men and then
the woman can answer how many bodies
yeah how many bodies does it take as in
like uh high level men or oh bodies I
thought you said Bodies Okay
um
in my experience
Sun changes after like
three people I know
if she slept with three people that
you've actually yeah
so I don't know I don't I don't have an
opinion for you know women before that
but when I meet someone or like you know
they come into the same scene as me Etc
if she's been with
more than
to brought more than two people but
definitely three then that's like
because so you're saying like you're
never gonna know the actual body count
so you kind of Base it by the number of
dudes that you know that she slept with
yeah so if you find out about three then
she's a hoe it's how you conduct
yourself yeah if I know two or three
guys in the room if I know two of you
guys in a general scene in London that
you've been with then it's um because
it's too much of a small walk so you've
been about no I'm about about no the
girl the girl if the girls had three men
that you know that means she's been
about to go all the way to the three
that you know in your life The
Coincidence also my boys are some of the
top guys in it so if if you've been with
one of my boys then I know
you know where you at yeah yeah
where's your hair that type vibes okay
what about you
[__] his wife's got one so is it two
you know what I'll be a little bit more
generous on that front maybe I'll say it
when you hit the double double figures
so ten yeah okay what about you
uh I'll maybe say when you roughly hit
above maybe over seven but then then
again some girls
be dating a lot but they're not really
hoeing but they'll be dating and
hopeless Romantics will fall in love and
you know what I'm saying and then I'll
add up so as he said like yeah when it
starts reaching 9 10 then it's like yeah
you just
okay so 9 10 what about you
so mine is kind of like age condition
okay so if you're like in your 20s and
you're over 10 yeah you're done if you
hit 30 and you're over 15 yes okay speak
so you say 15 by 30 10 before okay
ladies what do you guys think how many
bodies does it take for a girl to become
a hoe
um yeah I'll agree with you I think it's
like very age conditioned but I do think
like
I don't know because I know some people
like I think it's like a double digits
yeah that's when you like become a high
I think a hoe can reform
um
but then like oh this is kind of
embarrassing to admit but like I'm only
19. my I've never [__] before like
I've still never been [__] I'm still a
virgin I don't think it's embarrassing
obviously I've obviously done like stuff
we've got as nine guys to like count
um but people would still call me at
home because I like post provocative or
like I think it's just very subjective
on what you think a hoe is like I have
people call me a hoe every day because I
like post half naked but I've actually
never been [__] before and like all my
hoe in is like I've done like online
stuff and whatever but yeah there's
levels the whole window so that's why I
will say there's there's levels you know
you can get an escort that's gonna
everything you can get escort that's
going to talk to you on the phone like
there's levels I mean one level is
language right so
if you refer to yourself as like being
[__]
I'm very I'm very like confused or like
made lava yeah you want to use one of
the nice words you know
that's the whole language right there
I'm just really directly sorry
um uh what about uh you two haven't
answered yet
um I'm kind of like where I've forgotten
your name Alex Alex says
um like if I don't know then like who am
I to call you a hoe you know and
ah like I would probably say double
digits maybe but then I know friends
that are in double digits and I'm like I
love them so it's like [__] or as
people is
sues
you're nice home
this is what I call it but for me
but for me to use that language towards
somebody for me in that moment like I
can't say that I love somebody and call
them a hoe like it doesn't come in the
same sentence so like to me you're just
experienced life to its fullest wow yeah
I can't I can't call you a hoe and then
say I love you like they don't come in
the same sentence I wouldn't call
someone a hopeful stuff and
because I I think of a hoe as someone
who is who who sleeps around carelessly
yeah
yeah I think I think someone who sleeps
around consciously whether they've slept
with 10 you know 20 people whatever I
mean after after a point it's like it's
hard to consciously sleep with like 40
people but you know that that's that's
how I think of it so close to me have an
energy it's a spiritual Vibe it's like
that's Tendencies
well in Tantra they exchange energy on
so many different levels with people and
it's not classed as being a hoe like you
are there's no penetration energy but
for some people if you are touching so
like I'm a tantric practitioner and we
like we get taught how to do certain
things to people and it's not but and
you can give that service but would you
then class me as a horror like I don't
do that by the way but I mean for some
tantric practitioners but it's not
called our a prostitute or a horror the
government is very very very conscious
and it's a massive exchange of energy
that can be you can manifest you can do
something for women not for men I mean
Metals sleep with goddamn anything
no I don't feel that I'm at a space
where I am able to give that to somebody
because for me I would I need to be
really trusting of somebody to get to
that point of intimacy to that level
because I as much as I'm very out there
with my thoughts and opinions me
exchanging energy with you I understand
the level of energy that I am able to
give and so I can't just touch somebody
I know how to do it but I yeah you just
don't I just don't choose to yeah I was
gonna say then it means that in in a way
because it's conscious you exactly you
knowingly don't want to be exchanging
energy with so many people yeah so in a
way it will take a certain type of
person to do you take a hole to do that
[__] exactly what I was getting out of
my brother you got it all right I got
you bro how many how many bodies is Too
Many Bodies too
what's a hoe how many I think
friends
of my friends I'll be like
okay 15. yeah I think if I feel like if
you're my age 25 and you've slept over
15 then it's like
yeah
you must have gone gone through a dark
path something must have happened yeah
you've been streaming
and back to what you were saying I do
think people nowadays don't think sex is
like a big deal like it is a big deal
like for me to especially for a woman
like for me to let someone inside of me
that is literally so personal that is so
like that should only be shared with
someone I genuinely really care about
you guys can come out and wash their
dick and they're fine like actually
letting someone inside this is the same
as like you're becoming a part of me
basically for that period of time that
period of Time Forever DNA yes when a
man goes inside of you then DNA is
inside you for life you're you're
connected to that person on a soul level
it's not just oh yeah I can you can do
lots of rituals to try and get rid of
that [__] but at the same time that's
why girls that do sleep around you can
there
what do you what do you mean their DNA
is that well when somebody comes inside
you to be graphic like that's okay just
use condoms then
yeah I get that but I mean at the same
time not everybody is using condoms
that's why there's so many questions
someone's body is actually entering
yours no I'm just saying in terms of the
DNA thing for the rest of your life on
an energetic level on an energetic level
wrap it up still exchanging energy with
somebody so it's like yeah you can wrap
it up but I mean energy isn't just
inside this physical thing yeah just
trotting around what about you denava oh
it's not really award as in my
vocabulary
therefore
I would say
I'm trying to think of a different one
wait how is the female version of a simp
where you are eaten and you don't eat
that's it which means that if you're a
woman yeah and you're being used by men
because you are insecure because that's
when you're going to be likely to be
labeled a hoe you know what I'm saying
whereas I believe in sexual Freedom
which means that you shouldn't be
labeled anything for wanting to be with
a man I have money you see me because I
don't have a husband I'm gonna have sex
please give me a number
it depends it depends it depends like
for example I know women that step with
five men they'll be like actually do you
know what you're kind of loose but then
I know that people that slept with five
men that actually I'm like you know what
I understand why you do this okay
all right five a hoe or not a hoe yes
please yes it depends on the person you
know okay okay 50. you saw that my
teacher
please
I think she's maybe damaged okay
okay let's use the word damaged and
everyone else this means hell yeah
damage damaged is she damaged at 10.
depends on her intentions okay so maybe
how maybe not 15 is she damaged depends
on her intentions okay when does it
switch to yes
so when she's letting men go 20 is she
damaged
yeah depends on her intentions okay 30
is she damaged
I just want to know when it switches out
um let's say 30 by 30. under what
conditions how many were boyfriends
okay you know what for [__] to give
girls let's say half were boyfriends
then nah what if she was having
threesomes with her boyfriend how does
that change because if you haven't if
you're in a relationship for a long long
time maybe you want to open that stuff
I think anyone that does an open
relationship that like that's hopeless
I believe in sexual Liberation it
doesn't mean that you need to be labeled
all it means is how you feel about the
action that you're doing so I don't like
it I don't think there's anything
liberating for sex with women there is a
woman a woman has needs you really think
that woman doesn't know the most the
most but you can get your needs met by a
boyfriend or a husband yeah and that's
what I'm saying so sex is not really
what you should look on your body how is
it liberating to sleep around and not
call someone a hug no it is liberating
to be able to choose to have sex when
have we ever not been able to choose
listener and that's what I'm saying
no there's a difference though no
because this is the thing as a woman if
you are not able to make a choice yeah
based on who you are and what you want
then you are more likely to be damaged
because your decision making is cute if
you don't want to be having sex with men
but you you're using sex as a way to
validate your beauty to validate that
you are somebody that is desirable then
that is damage and a lot of women in
that situation some girls I think they
just enjoy sex literally some girls got
crazy sex drive so I'm done but why
can't you do that with one person that
knows exactly in and out what you like
because
you're lucky that you found somebody
I'm gonna agree with you on a level and
say like what what is this is what I
don't care about this space what is the
obsession with like judging other
people's sexual partners and like what
they do I don't understand how a grown
man will sit down and be like because we
have children with this many people you
know this right let me tell you let me
ask you a question because we have
children to raise and if I have five
girls I do not want somebody who is
sexually liberated to teach my young
female children to grow up in a world
that they feel like they can just go
around and sleep around
and ain't gonna have no repercussions
now no one's saying that you can't go
out and sleep with whoever you want to
no one's saying that but what we're
saying is that comes with repercussions
and consequences and the consequences
are if you're looking for a husband
you're going to be deemed less valuable
but I think so to some guys what were
you gonna say so forget what I was going
to say I just want to respond to what he
says I think um when you um when the
problem is that now social media are the
women people that have been sexually
liberated or whatever you want to call
it
um they say you know just do what you
want to be do just be free and I think I
mean as a woman I can't judge other
women like dude your thing it doesn't
affect me right it's not that I'm gonna
marry you but I think um the one thing
that lacks in our society right now is
the fact that there is no education for
consequences of what actually happens if
you sleep with 20 50 because I know
girls personally and I don't know three
four five ten girls I know multiple
girls that at my age have body counts of
over a hundred over 100.
what's the consequences from that
because you can catch an STD sleeping
with one person and you can catch an STD
sleeping 100.
my question is is what is the
consequence that you can't parabon for
example yeah it's mental you lose it why
don't you start comparing every man that
you slept with and no one is Ever Enough
yeah because you may find someone for
example our relationship someone might
look at it it's not perfect whatever but
for me it's perfect I can easily say
that it's personalized I mean you're
both like fitness models so I think
you're too different but but
next season like literally besides each
other yeah so the way I started and the
way that you started was literally yeah
we're growing up no no I'm not I'm not
in fact you said no no I've been a boxer
but he's I've been in the fitness team
yeah but what I was saying is like
there's always going to be something
right the fact that he freaking drops
his towel on the floor when he comes out
the bathtub that pisses me the [__] off
[Laughter]
the whole bed the fact that you know
there's certain things you're always
going to not like about a person there's
always little you know icks but nowadays
woman's list of icks are ridiculous and
then you look at your partner now you're
with at the moment and I and I see that
through some of my friends and they'll
say oh he's missing this and yeah and
then they'll see that in someone they
may be working with or they meet in a
club or whatever and all of a sudden
it's like oh he fulfills that 20 or that
10 and all of a sudden they're missing
out and then they go into that
relationship and they find out actually
but then they went into that one and
it's that one's missing it and they mess
up a good thing because they're looking
for the one thing that that guy didn't
have instead of just working with what
they got basically yeah as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible